تونس الايادي الخفيه عنوان تحقيق ما خفي
اعظم الجديد فالبلد يعيش اليوم استقطابا
حادا على وقع اتهامات للرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد بتوظيف القضاء لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه
مع معارضيه وفتح ملفات ضدهم كان ابرزها
ملف التسفير الذي يطاولت التحقيقات فيه
قيادات في المعارضه ونشطاء ورجال اعمال
لاتهامهم بتسهيل سفر شبان تونسيين لمناطق
التوتر في كل من سوريا وليبيا وغيرهما
احد الشهود الرئيسيين في هذه القضيه والذي
فتح له الهواء عبر وسائل اعلام محليه
وخارجيه وعصام الدردوري
يعني وجدلا في تونس رجل الامن ورئيس منظمه
الامن والمواطن عصام الدردوري حركه النهضه
ليست فقط سهلت عمليه تسوي الشباب الى بؤره
التوتر عرض تحقيق ما خفي اعظم تسريبات
تكشف ان الدردوري الشاهد في قضيه التزفير
متورط في تسفير وتسريب خطير هيا من رجال
المقاومه الاسلاميه في سوريا تسجيلات
صوتيه عرضها التحقيق كشفت مراسلات بين
عصام الدردوري وشخص لبناني يدعى محمد علي
اسماعيل يعمل لصالح النظام السوري صديقنا
الذي جلسنا معه في احدى مناسبات ويعني
المستشار الحكومي هو في ديوان الطائره
المدني والمطارات له علاقات يعني ممكن
يوصلنا لشؤون في هاي السياق تكشف
التسريبات انخراط الدردوري في تاجير
طائرات تونسيه بطرق غير رسميه والاخطر
وتسريب معلومات امنيه حساسه لمحمد علي
اسماعيل تتضمن صورا واسماء عناصر اختراق
جندها الامن التونسي خارج الحدود
بالنسبه للقرص المضغوط اللي فيه صور متاع
العناصر الغامقه بالاختراق والادرب في
الوحدات الامنيه اطلعت عليهم الصور كلهم
موجودين برجلين عندك والتسجيل شغال ماشي
الدردوري بدا انه اداه ضمن منظومه ارتبطت
بملفات عديده مثيره في تونس حيث برزت
الرجل في قضيه اتهامه بتجنيد فتاه لاسقاط
قاض تونسي ممن اشرف على التحقيق في احداث
امنيه مثيره اهمها حادثه المنيعله التي
وقعت في شهر مايو ايار عام 2016 وحصل ما
خفي اعظم على ملف وثائق التحقيق فيها
فالعمليه التي قدمت للمجتمع التونسي
باعتبارها اكتشافا لمجموعه من المسلحين
المتطرفين واحباطا لمساعيهم نحو تنفيذ
عمليات مسلحه في البلاد اسفرت عن قتل
اثنين من المسلحين واعتقال عدد اخر
ومصادره اسلحه وذخائر حسب الروايه الرسميه
لكنها لم تكن في الحقيقه بحسب الوثائق
التحقيقات سوى عمليه مفبركه بايدي قاده في
جهاز الحرس الوطني بقياده لطف براهم انذاك
والذي تقلد لاحقا منصب وزير الداخليه
وغيرها بحسب الوثائق التي عرضها التحقيق
استخدم فيها ضباط في الحرس الوطني عناصر
اختراق للجماعات المسلحه جندوا لتنفيذ هذه
العمليات منهم ما يزال يعملون واخرون
اشتكوا تخلي هذا الجهاز عنه التونسي يا
زينب كشرود التي واجهت مصيرا مريرا
اعتقلها الامر الجزائري على الحدود ولم
تفلح رسائل استغاثتها من داخل السجن للامن
التونسي للتدخل بغيه الافراج عنها بعدما
كانت مجنده في مهمه اختراق باشراف ضباط في
جهاز الحرس الوطني ملفات امنيه عالقه
والشخصيات المتورطه فيها لم تطاولها ايادي
المحاسبه وهو ما يثير كثيرا من التساؤلات
حول منظومه امنيه وسياسيه عميقه ما زالت
تتح في المشهد التونسي رغم تقلب وتبدل
المسارات السياسيه